ça va et toi
ouais voilà tienne maintiennent une
émission ne vois plus je vois c'est pour
ça à mon avis c'est pour ça qu'elle peut
marcher parce qu'on me voit plus
j'imagine que ça peut marcher ça peut
aider oui parfois c'est quoi ton parfum
sent bon cash à rabat à la pêche
bon oui ma vue ah oui la jeune femme va
avoir dix ans il dépasse bientôt prête
et puis ça va ça se passe bien l'école
ça se passe bien on construit abattoirs
lieu au conservatoire où il apprend quoi
bientôt peut-être nous sommes fais là il
est en quatrième année de solfège et une
halle passer leur deuxième année de là
nous mettre aussi doué que son grand
père et son père
aucune idée je veux changer et comment
il s'appelle alors à l'école lucien
ginsburg du sia
bur mais les cris des chiens baseball
gainsbourg les mômes à l'école ils
savent que c'est le fils de guillaume
blot c'est chiant c'est chiant parce que
sans arrêt c'est y rentre de l'école en
pleurs parce qu'on lui a dit que j'étais
une came que son père était à came que
son père c'est un sale con parce qu'il a
brûlé un billet de 500 balles donc lui
sa sale con il est jugé toujours à
travers nous orienter à tout faire
traiter de rien voir
j'imagine donc ça touche vraiment ce que
je veux moi moi quand c'est moi je lui
explique que bon je vais aller à l'école
que je vais aller voir les parents et
tout ça mais avant il casser la gueule
qu'on me disait quoi que ce soit sur
nous maintenant je lui dis que tu
essayes de passer sur tout ça puis à il
a du mal
et toi et comme ça plus petits qui lui a
dit ça il m'a dit je veux pas décider
quand j'ai dit quand ils sont atteints
auteurs maintenant tu leur casse la
gueule et de ma part mais j'ai demandé à
rencontrer les parents les parents
veulent pas passer j'imagine que c'est
pas les mômes content de ça mais moi ma
femme a inventé que certains brûlés un
billet de 500 balles quoi mais dès que
ça touche son père
mais bon à l'épaule
oui pour rien moi j'entends bien ils
arrivent à avoir 16 14 mois yann ouais
c'est un fainéant génial quoi ça finit
en tout court ouais il est génial pour
plein d'autres choses
nous sommes à serge assumant un petit
peu [ __ ]
il sait qu'ils étaient en berne ont bien
sûr atteint comme ça j'ai deux parties
l'avaient toussaint quand ils
l'apprennent souvent
à chaque fois qu'il en ait débat non toi
consorts nous prête à me soucier pas de
l'oie de chez teal pour les chaussures
il laisse partir le maliciel ne visait
pas pape a pour lui son père il est
magique
il peut le voir mais n'ont pu le voir
non pas relus par ben on parle de nuit
au présent donc c'est pas vraiment bien
au bout de quatre ans choix ce n'a
toujours par semaine
et on est tous les deux chez un
thérapeute
je sais pas ça va marcher ne ment on
espère faut pas mourir qu'on pas trop tu
sais que c'est à cause de serge que j'ai
fait des enfants mois ben c'est seul
truc bien que sur lequel j'étais tombé
quand il est parti ou tout le monde
disait ce qu'il pensait de gainsbourg et
toi tu as dis juste une chose
serge la façon dont il parlait de son
fils m'a donné envie d'avoir des enfants
et justement j'en ai fait je pensais pas
peur mais à partir du moment où
gainsbourg effet des enfants je me suis
moi aussi j'en avais déjà fait avant
mais moi c'est la façon d'une des
premières interviews j'avais fait
c'était j'avais dit c'est d'ailleurs ce
v10 mec tout ce que tu t'en vois tu
avais pas peur que le petit lulu sont un
peu mongolo hessels avait choqué certes
j'étais arrivé à choquer tout dépend de
la moins bien placée pour savoir si
l'amendé comme pendant la grossesse
l'enfant risque mais une fois que c'est
dans le tiroir bien que la mort moi il
sage ya aucun problème
ça a été ma chance nous écouter des
chansons moi au départ ça a été très
difficile et surtout quand ils passent à
la télé et lui m'a dit maintenant c'est
la seule façon dont tu peux voir mon
père c'est à télé et nos tentes cd
cassettes
c'est tous les jours n'est besoin sont
comme moi vous écoutez quoi il aime bien
les vieilles chansons
ouais ouais deux premières chansons il
aimait beaucoup aux enfants de la chance
mais ça tout petit quand il avait deux
ans et demi sa chanson préférée au
réveil c'était aux enfants de la chance
à et puis là il aime bien aimé les
chansons comme ubi bene vitesse initiale
du bilan et il ya une chanson qu'ils
n'avaient marqué c'était d'octobre
docteur jekyll y avait il à vue j'ai pas
à la télé
son père était dans un fauteuil hop le
fauteuil tourner hop il y à là il a
disparu alors il a trouvé ça génial
c'était magique
il aime bien toute cette époque il adore
le poinçonneur des lilas et puis il a
une oreille presque parfaite donc il
entend trois notes il sait que son père
de ce film mais je sais pas ce qui fera
j'espère qu'il fera pas la même chose
que serge pourquoi ça risque d'être
difficile pour lui quoi bon déjà c'est
pas facile petit tu vois là dessus mais
ce nom mais bon si après on doit être
doué que son père moisson
nagl parce que je ne cours pas moi ça ne
m'enchante pas vraiment mais enfin bref
mais quel âge qu'on a rencontré serge
disney
non ça rajeunit ça rajeunit personne non
infectée
tu peux me passer une clope ouais tiens
ap la tuer mais d'autres mecs de pluie à
ton avis non
je pense que c'est difficile quoi et je
suis poli mais trop comment j'y suis
déjà une forme de court je suis pas une
sainte
mais bon je peux être au courant quoi tu
sais tu es à faire exactement la même
chose
tu sors un peu
à vos points
costard juste ferasse dix minutes le
samedi
le soir là
mel gibson toi fais des gages à ta pour
que je m'assoie à côté de lui enfin je
suis désolé de dire ça à temps il est
venu s'asseoir à côté de moi mais j'ai
senti ac sur la table tu vois moi je
suis parti j'ai détourné et grimper sur
l'olympe devant le monument des
monsieurs excusez moi c'était tellement
lord alge être lourd parfois les
américains n'étaient pas bons il vaut
mieux des fatwas gare déminage des gens
comme tout les voit dans le film
présente vraiment ajouté d'abord non je
pensais pas qu'il était si petit
sceptiques moi toi
vous savez à gros coups assez vite j'ai
tout par mel gibson est non autant il
était bien dakar c'est tout parce
qu'après 9 gilles arriver à être drôle
dans l'âme cet âge c'est beaucoup rire
lui
ça mais bon bref
elle va changer trop je trouve ouais toi
non plus c'est dommage qu'on ne voit pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux